marxists are very pro-god because the
argument do you know what i'm writing
about this my upcoming book the white
pill
the fir there's a myth among the boomer
conservatives that gun control started
as a result
of they didn't want like uh black people
to become armed um
post civil war said that it actually
started in illinois
because a lot of these labor unions were
forming militias
and they were drilling because they were
ready to start a revolution
and this was a big problem it's like
wait a minute the second amendment
specifically says you should have a
militia
they're forming labor militias in the
idea of eventually killing the
capitalists and taking over
and this was a huge supreme court case
and they lost and that's where gun
control really kind of started
what year was it i think 1870 so so
and then and then within like a couple
decades was it called the haymarket
massacre was that what it was
that you're don't spoil my book but yes
that's in chicago was that in chicago
that is in chicago yes yeah that was
what
happened without someone through
dynamite or something okay so okay this
is this is the story of lewis link who's
on the cover of the anarchist handbook
which i'll be back on
uh to talk about when it's ready
assuming i don't burn this bridge today
um who knows it's a live show let's
start this
is made of glass so everybody
understands the context you're saying
that gun control starts with these labor
unions
and now we're talking about the hey mars
hey market massacre it's a very
very quick transition so what happens is
in illinois you have these
they're very heavily immigrant very
heavily german uh labor unions are
forming malicious and they're they're
they're mustering i think that's the
term when they're you know practicing so
on and so forth
there was a union meeting in haymarket
square in chicago which is
still around and different people were
talking
uh at night a bomb got thrown dynamite
a lot of people got killed including
several police officers a bunch of
anarchists
were rounded up some of whom were not
even there
and they were accused of conspiracy to
commit murder because they were
advocating these radical ideas
one of them was someone named lewis ling
if you look him up on the internet
he looks like channing tatum it looks
like a contemporary photo even though
it's from 1870 something it's crazy
what is it louis lange ling l-i-n-g-g
he's the stud of anarchism he was the
first che guevara
basically i'm not kidding i'm not right
i'm impressed yeah he's a hunk
so they put these anarchists on trial
lewis ling they had searched his house
and there was a lot of dynamite in his
house
and his lawyer said weekly well he's got
to write down dynamite his house
this has become a meme where lewis ling
is alleged to have said i couldn't have
thrown that bomb
i was at home making bombs because he
wasn't there but a bomb
but a bomb got thrown they were
sentenced to death
they were all hanged louis was one of
the four of them were excuse me
or five lewis escaped the hanging
because he snuck in a blasting cap into
his jail cell
blew off his jaw and then wrote in blood
on the wall
hooray for anarchy the others
one of them when he was being hanged
said someday
the voices you strangle uh will
be louder than the someday the i forget
the term whatever
there's a they got pardoned many years
later and there's a memorial to them
right now in chicago but this is where a
lot of it started the gun control stuff
yes wow well we so the conservatives
it's funny the aclu
also got started defending communists uh
because it was
this radical revolutionary idea so a lot
of conservatives like like to adopt
these
ideas and they don't realize where the
origins are from the radical radical
left so this could have been a false
flag
like the legal the law could have thrown
dynamite in and blaming that's what they
said
they said this was this is an agent
provocateur paid for by the capitalists
to get us in trouble and we still don't
know who threw the bomb to this day so
let's wrap this back
to uh uh the origin of how we start
talking about this which was uh
the chauvin trial they're they're going
after one guy
derek shovin if they convict him the
state
which in my opinion is responsible will
cheer and hurrah
and all of the activists will be
satisfied well probably not but
if the idea is they want chauvin put on
trial as the individual
they're ignoring what's really going on
and i likened this to
you know i'll put it exactly like this
it's like imagine if that there was a
you know in fetal japan the ninja was
tasked with taking out the emperor
instead he fought with
the palace guard and then celebrated
when the palace guard one of them
you know was removed from his post
chauvin is just one guy who works for a
system
getting that guy convicted won't change
anything and he was just some guy
who was doing like you know he was told
here's how you restrain someone
now whether or not he actually did
anything wrong in that capacity stopping
floyd
i disagree with the war on drugs but
there's arguments about what you do when
there's when there's statutory law in
the books
derek chauvin was trained by the
minneapolis police to do
it's called the recovery position that's
what it said in the training thing that
they released
because if you put your knee on their
back they could asphyxiate so he
literally moves his knee
should this guy be convicted after
everything we've seen with all the
evidence
chauvin with the fentanyl in his system
with a guy who now it appears to be a
dealer
you know he appeared to be high uh floyd
said before he was even restrained did
you see this i can't breathe he said it
before he was even restrained
so all of that leads to the conclusion
of at least bare minimum reasonable
doubt
my problem the war on drugs first and
foremost is a big part of this
especially when i saw you know floyd's
girlfriend testify about
opioid addiction and what they were
going through and i was like this is
insane man
that we're doing this the problem i have
is the activists who are angry
are being easily distracted and pointing
at one guy and when he's convicted
nothing will change
they will not do anything there's two
things one they want to make an example
of him to make
the other customer online two is i just
want to point out what the slog
the thing on the memorial is because
it's a great quote he said um this is
august
who's one of the ones who was hanged he
says the day will come when our silence
will be more powerful than the voice
you're struggling today
so i think that's the case with a lot of
people who are killed by the state it's
that they are silenced
but you know what they represent which
might not actually be accurate
you know speaks speaks volumes yeah well
michael the state realized that and so
now they go for character assassination
instead sure
they they learned they learned a while
back and i'm surprised it took him as
long as it did to be honest
when they were like hey if we got a
problem we just kill him and then it's
like well congratulations you've made a
martyr who's immortal now
right so they have to smear your
reputation and make you a nasty diddler
or something and then all of a sudden
your legacy is destroyed and nobody
wants to reference your name anymore
and they're trying to do that with the
trump administration there were several
articles written how they're trying to
make
people trying to make anyone who worked
for him radioactive and unhirable
remember it was tough for the former
president to i mean
your job as defense attorneys to defend
child abu users you know murderers
rapists like the most horrible people
that's your job
they were having trouble finding people
to defend the sitting the
the sitting room at the time former
president uh for the impeachment trial
and now you see what facebook said right
now
the voice of the president is not
allowed on their platform i saw that
yeah the voice of
larry trump yeah what was that lara
trump the president's uh
daughter-in-law um she interviewed him
he didn't say anything particularly
inflammatory didn't talk about the
election
they pulled the video and they said you
cannot have
trump's voice on our site so they have
ai
just clocking trump's voice ready to
pull up no they knew no apparently
yeah when she expressed her intention
yeah and they sent an email saying like
just so you know if you do this
you're gone and then she was like i'm
gonna do it anyway and i was like right
on
they're trying to vanish a president
from existence
who's still alive this is let me ask you
do you think that the moves being made
by the establishment today
are something new or do you think those
individuals in this power structure has
always existed but slipped up
i i think they're losing their power i
think these are the same moves
um they're trying to make people making
people radioactive has happened
for a very long time in this country and
i think they have to ramp it up
because if there's three networks abc
cbs nbc
the three of us can get in a room and be
like look this guy's a clown
we're not going to repeat him yes yes
yes shake hands that's why a lot of
ideas that were kind of on the fringe
would be heard by the mainstream because
it's like the three of them said yeah
we're not going to talk about it
now when you have this show and infinite
shows on youtube on
rumble and all these other other
locations it's impossible to have a
monopoly of the megaphone
so now they're freaking out because it's
very difficult to sustain
uh a regime based on mistruths or
untruths
when all it takes is one jerk with a
twitter account to be like
uh this is inaccurate and then your
whole facade falls like finding out your
wife has been cheating on you
maybe she cheated on you once but that
changes the whole 10 years
the crazy thing about it is you know
what we're seeing with the censorship or
seeing with stephen crowder
it's it's clearly insane and it's it's
like every single time a new story
happens it's worse than it's been why do
you say what do you mean by insane
because when
when i when i i heard about this when i
was doing my north korea book a lot of
times people say insane when they just
don't understand
the system and a lot of times the system
is coherent i mean insane as in
in the figurative that it's so
shockingly outrageous
it would make anyone think the world is
you know gone nuts or i just mean insane
as in like is a hyperbolic this is all
right
what is going on this is this is dialed
up to 11 yeah yeah
crowder broke no rule he did not break a
single rule i know because i've spoken
with google on the phone with google
representatives on the phone
about their rules it's really
interesting i wonder if crowder will sue
them for defamation
because what they're telling people is
that
in these articles where people ask about
crowder they say that he violated
their deceptive policy or spam policy
but the specific email that got sent out
by google said you can't do this
particular thing
crowder did not do that particular thing
he said you can't say these two things
the same time crowder did not say those
two things
but then they tell the press he violated
that rule
well that's a false statement of fact he
didn't they claimed he
they removed a video for trying to uh
you know circumvent his restriction
he didn't the rules clearly state or at
least google has said
you can upload to another channel if the
content is substantially different
which it was he filmed a cell phone
video saying hey guys here's what's
happening it wasn't his normal show
too bad they said so this is this is
crazy right
now here's the thing even if they get
rid of crowder and it really does feel
like as time goes on they're they are
strangling these networks but can i
interrupt because there's
there's all these names that we that
they've successfully picked off one by
one that we forget about
remember nick monroe yes yes absolutely
i remember he was
he i mean he was a badass on twitter who
is he he was a twitter journalist shout
out to nick if he's watching
and he would be breaking a lot of
stories because there would be something
in the corporate press
and he would just he was this nerdy kid
with a computer and a lot of spare time
and he'd do his due diligence and he'd
find articles like
what you're saying is is not accurate
here's the receipts
they got rid of him carpe dunked him who
was president trump's meme maker
this guy is basically making memes for
the president things they're going viral
they yanked him shout out to my friend
carpenter so there and there's others
that we can name that thing
milo was a shocking one to me that was
like i don't know that was the shocking
to me
not shocking he put in his twitter
profile that he worked for buzzfeed it
was that they banned
right the fact that when it comes to
these higher profile personalities
uh none of them should be banned by the
way i just don't think so um
they colluded or at the very least they
were like waiting for the moment when
they could all act in concert
and for some reason did although it's
not completely unified
because like twitter waits a day or two
before they finally do it well they
waited a while for alex jones
right yeah that's another one but that
that collusion but it it's very
but the thing is like i'll play devil's
advocate to some extent
i don't think people appreciate how weak
a lot of corporate america
is and no one wants to stick out their
neck so it's a lot easier for me
as jack dorsey if youtube and zuckerberg
are all doing this
for me to be like there's no cost for me
to join them but if i'm sticking my neck
out like we saw with black lives matter
and the guy who ran crossfit
and he's like this has nothing to do
with us we're we're you know gay
exercise organization they're like well
you know now you're the odd one out yeah
so very much group thing does play into
this is
not necessarily nefarious uh well here's
what i wonder
obviously there is a mainstream and
youtube will
will pick off one by one all these big
channels and they're really homogenizing
everything i don't know how long
will last a lot of people are like dude
we'll never get banned you do milk toast
even though facebook already removed me
nick monroe is i mean i'm not going to
call you milk toast mickey monroe was
not some kind of radical yeah
they said he was circumvention yeah but
so
even after they do that the the
technology
cryptocurrency your own private websites
open source text still exists
crowder has a website he has mug club
he's got uh uh you know he's with blaze
tv
they can reduce a decent amount of his
reach on their platforms
but in the end look at what happens when
trump gets you gets banned off uh
twitter people start losing followers
like crazy right
a lot of people were only on twitter for
the president in the first place
when patreon banned carl benjamin who
now runs the lotus eaters podcast which
you guys should check out
i lost a ton of support from people who
are messaging me saying dude
love your work but i'm here for a lot of
people and i have to move now because
you know my like
my favorite show is you know carl's show
so i'm getting off of patreon
and then i had no choice if i stayed on
i would have lost 20 or 25 percent
of mine you went through that personally
i didn't know you were on patreon i went
through it two or two i was on patreon
didn't that sam harris left
dave rubin launched locals now i'm on
malice.locals.com it's a patreon
facebook hybrid people can
it's free to join five bucks if you want
to contribute the point
look i know you're not a fan whatever
the point is i got off patreon the
second i could
there was an alternative because it's
not a sustainable
career as a creative type to know that
overnight
i could have all my work vanished
without any recourse without any
explanation whereas now
i can call reuben up and be like yo
what's going on and have an actual
response i think that's a very big
difference
and a lot of people had the ability to
call jack conte of patreon to do the
same thing
okay i did not have that ability right
right so so right now
the issue i take and look i i think
dave's great i think he's a friend
uh um and local sounds awesome my issue
is and always
will be centralizing
basically joining any of these platforms
means
they could remove me whenever they want
and what do you think is going to happen
and and i mean wait
a minute who they who mean locals or me
personally right right right now it's
dave rubin he can snap his fingers and
destroy your career
i i don't know about that or like um i
mean your income
your stream everything you've posted on
locals but i mean and i'd be a little
hyperbolic with my career
you've got other platforms i thought you
meant being hyperbolic about they did
you have a career
fair a little bear i am here fair there
um but i i mean that's it that's a
function of anything if you're going to
be a waiter if you're going to be a chef
i mean you're going to have some owner
someone's going to unless you're totally
sure employed so reduce that amount
sure you're singing my song that's why
we started timcast.com
i was like why should i be on someone
else's platform i should make my own
and what my plan is now we've talked
about it quite a bit ian's recommended
some some developers you might have
we're going to make an open source
plugin that anyone could just drop on
their own website which creates the full
package subscription model
and i have no control over it that's a
great that's a great idea absolutely
that's it
this is this i am going to with this
project
attempt i will say to destroy all of
these subscription services every single
one of them
and more power to you i think what this
is something that i i get into a lot on
twitter
people are so because they sarcastically
say oh just build your own patreon
just build your own website it's like
there's a lot of smart people
who are seeing these problems coming
down the road it's hard to miss these
problems are godzilla sized
and all it's going to take is one smart
person here you go
and be like this is going to be a
workaround and once this problem is
solved it is solved
permanently i'm old enough i'm 63
to remember when the idea i'm old enough
to remember
when people said the idea of oh make
your own website would have been an
absurdity
now it takes 10 minutes 10 minutes yeah
you get a wordpress plugin yeah and
they're amazing so so yes
we want to start i mean look you don't
need a lot for your own subscription
service like timcast.com is not this
it's
it's not the biggest thing in the world
it's it's a relatively simple wordpress
from the new members we got we were able
to make a better website launching soon
which is now pro and from those members
we're not gonna start funding
tv shows movies and i actually i read
through a treatment for a show
we might produce this is amazing stuff
it's gonna be awesome
i want to create an open source project
that someone could just install on a web
server like they find a hosting company
they install it boom
when you go to their website it looks
like any of these subscription services
it's got a login sign up function it's
got a database now there's some things
you have to be responsible for security
things like that
your own payment processors things like
that it'll probably be striper paypal
like most people use
but it'll be like one click boom package
upload your website exists
then you'll have all the wordpress
functioning for for uploading photos and
you'll have you have a little bit of a
learning curve but for the most part you
will have
a totally decentralized patreon system
let me let me let me tell you
i talked to jack conti of patreon a
couple times
when uh people got banned and just to
for a lot of people who may you know not
understand what's going on patreon is a
is a subscription service
they abruptly banned lauren southern
eliminating her income they later
abruptly banned carl benjamin
eliminating his income
and let's uh just to people understand
abruptly means it's not like youtube
where you get a strike it's like you
wake up and
all your names are gone all your money's
gone any money that they had in escort
they pulled for you you're not seeing a
penny of this
this is very sudden and it's out of
nowhere and you're not given warnings
this is
people need to appreciate how extreme
this is so lauren southern got pulled
overnight without warning wakes up one
day to find out her income stream is
just gone
then they said don't worry we'll never
do it again and then they did it again
to carl benjamin
what i was told long story short in a pr
in a phone call with jack hunty i talked
to him for a long time
on a couple different occasions i'll
give you the gist of it
without telling you necessarily
specifics without respect is privacy in
that regard but it's simple the
sentiment was this
when one of our partners comes to us and
says we're going to shut down your
entire website
unless you get rid of one person i have
a choice to make yeah ten thousand
people's careers and those livelihoods
or one well the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few my
response was
tell them to shove off and then when
those ten thousand people and all their
ten thousand followers or one million
followers each
are wondering what happened i'll point
them in your direction instead
they just give up so i'll tell you this
much as i respect dave rubin
what do you think would happen if
mastercard
called him up like like like they did to
patreon and they say
if you don't get rid of malice we shut
your company down overnight
well let's just pretend he's saying
bridge of fedex because she's much more
expendable with me love you
love you we don't have to we don't have
to argue about this because this
actually happened
so cody wilson who is awesome who's the
guy behind ghost guns
yes uh defense distributed wearing the
shirt right now um
he had something called hatreon and he
was trying to make a patreon alternative
where people who are banned from patreon
can go there and patreon
people who are heretics and his issue
why he had to shut it down
is because precise like you said visa or
strike one of the payment process says
no we're not doing business with you if
you can't get money from person eight
for
person b it's really not over the
internet there's nothing mecca's going
to change
everyone's flipping out like malice
you're ignoring this how's the market to
solve from this i'm telling people right
now
whether it's through crypto or some
other mechanism there are a lot of smart
people
who are who see this for the problem
that it is
and are taking steps to work around this
and this is something that absolutely
has to happen
but i'm sure you know even better than i
do people who are doing this and trying
to have the work around so that visa
doesn't have that kind of you by the
throat thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you